I’m gonna let you finish, but my last video
was the greatest video of all time!
Talk about God Complex…
Hey guys, Amy here talking God Complexes on
DNews today, which I can promise you Trace
does not actually have!
We’ve all heard about a God Complex. Donald
Trump is one current celebrity accused of
having one. His outward arrogance and overall
mean public demeanor are typical of a highly
narcissistic leader.
But what exactly is a God Complex? And is
it a real psychological affliction?
Properly called Narcissistic Personality Disorder,
a so-called God Complex is a rare mental disorder
characterized by an inflated sense of self-importance,
entitlement, a deep need for admiration, and
an alarming lack of empathy for other people.
And it can get extreme to the point where
someone with NPD doesn’t even see the people
around them as human. It’s an obsessive
preoccupation with status and power that gives
NPD the moniker “God Complex.”
But that confidence is typically a veneer
masking such cripplingly low self-esteem that
the slightest criticism can lead to a complete
breakdown. This makes the need for admiration
stronger, which in turn adds to the individual’s
inflated sense of self-worth. It’s a bit
of a disastrous cycle.
Like so many mental disorders, it’s not
entirely known what causes NPD, though it’s
thought to be rooted in either excessive pampering
or criticism from parents or a genetic predisposition,
and it typically affects more males than females
beginning in the teen years or early adulthood.
A 2012 study the journal Personality and Individual
Differences found that people who scored higher
on a Narcissistic Personality Inventory tended
to have more Facebook friends, tag themselves
in more pictures, and update their statuses
more frequently. This all points to someone
showing how great they are with no interest
in anyone else, but that doesn't just play
out online.
Unsurprisingly, a narcissistic personality
disorder can affect so many areas of someone’s
life, leading to unfulfilling relationships,
a problematic professional career, financial
troubles, and alcohol abuse, all of which
will ultimately isolate the one with the God
complex even more.
But does extreme narcissism make someone a
good leader? There’s conflicting answers
on any correlation between narcissism and
people who end up in strong leadership positions.
One 2014 study from the University of Nebraska
Lincoln says no. Narcissism can be useful
in certain situations and over-the-top confidence
in an interview scenario can be useful, but
in the end narcissists are more likely to
take undue risks and alienate their coworkers,
weakening their overall position. Business
Insider, however, disagrees, pointing to the
same traits the Nebraska studies find negative
to be positive. Narcissists, the article argues,
demonstrate vision, attract followers, are
highly persuasive, and unafraid to take risks.
But there’s no clear cut answer to whether
narcissists make natural leaders. As the Harvard
Business Review points out in a 2000 article,
narcissism tends to come hand-in-hand with
a crippling distrust in others, meaning even
the most accomplished narcissists can become
known for self–involvement, unpredictability,
and paranoia, all qualities that don’t make
for the best leaders, or friends or even presidential
candidates.
So are you a narcissist? Let us know in the
comments below and don’t forget to subscribe
for more DNews every day of the week.